The scientists
Koreans may have just made the
greatest discovery
of the last 50 years.
It could allow our phones
to never again fall to
battery short
and all this is possible thanks to the superconductor at room temperature.
But then why are they so amazing?
In fact,
normal conductors such as copper lose energy in the form of heat during the
electricity transport
This is the reason why your phones heat up during charging
but the superconductors have zero electrical resistance
that allows them to pass electricity perfectly without any loss.
Capacities could revolutionize technology
design by eliminating cooling systems and enabling
store the energy of a battery indefinitely.
We have invented superconductors in the
past but they only worked at temperatures
extremely low or at extremely high pressures
and this is where the introduction of the
potential superconductor nca99 is a game changer.
This one would work at 1 pirature time there is 1 ambient
pressure thus eliminating the need for extreme cooling method.
While this experiment can be replicated on a large
scale it could lead to the invention of energy shield
flying cars and affect every industry requiring electricity.
There are still many questions about the validity of
this research
but if it materializes it would be its impact for the future.